hola a todos en los siguientes vídeos
voy a estar hablando acerca de algo
llamado el jacob ya no y más
específicamente el determinante asociado
a la matriz hakobyan a déjame escribirlo
en los siguientes vídeos vamos a estar
hablando acerca de esta matriz hakobyan
pero en este vídeo sólo quiero hablar
acerca del conocimiento previo que voy a
suponer que ya entendemos para trabajar
esta matriz hakobyan a porque para
entender la matriz hakobyan am lo que
necesitamos son antecedentes de álgebra
lineal y en particular quiero asegurarme
de que aquí todos entiendan cómo pensar
acerca de las matrices y quiero
asegurarme de que aquí todos entiendan
cómo pensar acerca de las matrices como
transformaciones del espacio y cuando
digo transformaciones permítanme colocar
por aquí una matriz déjame tomarme no
sea voy a tomar la siguiente matriz no
voy a tomar la matriz 2 1 déjame ponerlo
con este color
2 1 y en la otra columna me voy a tomar
no sé menos 3 - 3 1
ya verás ahorita porque estoy
escribiendo esta matriz de dos colores
distintos pero si a esta matriz la
multiplicó no sé
imagínate que la vamos a multiplicar por
un vector bidimensional llamado el
vector x bien entonces
recordemos que obtengo de multiplicar
esta matriz por este vector bueno esto
me va a dar un vector de dos componentes
que se va a ver más o menos así tendrían
dos por equis déjame ponerlo con sus
respectivos colores
que multiplica a x ok ya esto hay que
sumarle menos 3 porque entonces me
quedaría más menos 3 que multiplica y ya
está en nuestra primera componente de
este vector y en la segunda componente 1
por x más 1 porque así que puedo poner
aquí x aquí voy a poner más aquí voy a
poner
james y déjame poner los respectivos
unos aquí voy a tener uno por equis y
aquí voy a tener uno por jim y bueno
observa que obtuve un vector de dos
dimensiones tienen dos componentes y lo
importante de todo esto es tener una
comprensión geométrica profunda de lo
que significa en realidad tomar el
vector xy y multiplicarlo por esta
matriz para obtener este vector 2x menos
3 james
x más bien en la segunda componente y
sobre todo entender que a esto de aquí
le llamamos una transformación lineal lo
que quiero es que entendamos que es una
transformación lineal así que lo que voy
a hacer es simplemente mostrarles cómo
se ve esta transformación en particular
en la gráfica del lado izquierdo donde
cada uno de estos puntos de esta
cuadrícula le voy a decir a la
computadora oye si este punto fuera x
james entonces quiero que me lo
transformes en el punto 2 x menos 3 y en
la primera componente y en la segunda
componente x + y aquí puedes ver cómo se
ven todos los puntos en el espacio se
mueven y terminan en este estado final
ahora hay un par de cosas que quiero
hacer notar la primera de ellas es que
todas las rectas de esta cuadrícula
permanecen paralelas y uniformemente
separadas y la segunda que es muy
importante es que siguen siendo rectas
no se curvan de alguna manera y eso es
muy especial esa es la forma geométrica
en la que pueden pensar una
transformación link
y podrás pensarlo así decir las rectas
permanecen rectas y en particular las
rectas de la cuadrícula donde empezamos
aquí empezaron como verticales y
horizontales y cuando aplicamos la
transformación siguen siendo paralelas y
siguen estando uniformemente separadas y
otra cosa a notar aquí es que si nos
regresamos y observas estos dos vectores
resaltados el vector de verden y el
vector de rojo estos dos comenzaron
justo aquí observa los comenzaron como
vectores va a ser cierto el vector verde
que tenemos aquí es el vector 10 déjame
ponerlo 10 ok
mientras que el otro vector este que
tenemos de color rojo es el vector 0 1
lo voy a escribir 0 1 y bueno si ahora
regresamos para acá y notamos en donde
caen bajo esta transformación entonces
cuando la matriz es multiplicada por
cada uno de estos vectores en el espacio
el lugar donde cae el vector verde el
que comenzó como el 10
ahora tiene coordenadas 21 y eso
corresponde muy directamente con el
hecho de que en la primera columna de
esta matriz tengamos justo al 21 y luego
del mismo modo el segundo vector el
vector 01 termina en las coordenadas
menos 1 - 2 - 3 menos 3,1 y eso
corresponde con el hecho de que la
segunda columna de esta matriz tengamos
al menos 31 y en realidad es bastante
sencillo ver por qué esto es cierto voy
a continuar y multiplicar la matriz que
teníamos la matriz original que bueno ya
es bastante fácil de encontrar si
observas tenemos aquí el vector 21
entonces pongo 21 y el vector menos 31
entonces pongo menos 3
1 y bueno ahora lo que quiero ver es en
realidad qué es lo que está pasando con
las columnas para que nos den el punto
en donde acaban los vectores va a ser
cuando le aplicamos la transformación
cuando la multiplicamos por esta matriz
y ahora cuando tomas la multiplicación
de esto por el primer vector observa
vamos a multiplicar esto por el vector
10 entonces noten a que nos va a llevar
bueno nos va a llevar al vector que
tiene como coordenadas 2 x 1 lo cual es
2 más y después tengo menos 3 x 0 lo
cual es cero ok y en la segunda
componente tengo uno por uno lo cual es
uno más uno por cero lo cual es cero así
que los únicos términos que en realidad
importan son estos dos el 2 y el 1 y
vamos a llegar al vector de hecho al
vector 2 1 déjame ponerlo al vector 2
1 del mismo modo si tomamos a la misma
matriz déjame ponerla de nuevo a la
matriz 21 menos 31 y ahora lo multiplicó
por el otro vector canónico por el
vector 01 entonces vamos a ver qué
obtenemos de esta multiplicación y si
observas esto me va a dar 2 x 0 lo cual
es 0 más menos 3 por 1 lo cual es menos
3 y después tengo 1 x 0 lo cual es 0 + 1
x 1 lo cual es 1 y si observas justo lo
que hace este 0 es eliminarlos esta
columna y me quedo simplemente con este
vector voy a llegar justo al vector
menos 3
y como dije geométricamente el
significado de una transformación lineal
es que las rectas de la cuadrícula
permanecen paralelas y uniformemente
separadas y cuando empiezan a pensar un
poco acerca de eso se puede saber en
dónde cae este vector verde y dónde caen
este vector rojo eso va a bloquear en su
lugar donde la cuadrícula completa debe
ir así que permíteme mostrarte a qué me
refiero y como corresponde esto con tal
vez una definición diferente a la que
hayas escuchado para lo que significa
una transformación lineal es decir que
si tenemos algún tipo de función l que
va a adoptar un vector y nos va a
arrojar otro vector se dice que es
lineal si satisfacen dos propiedades la
primera es que cuando tengan una
constante que multiplican a ese vector
al vector que vamos a meter entonces nos
des de respuesta la constante que
multiplican a esta función que es lineal
que está aplicada a su vez
al vector esta es la primera propiedad
de otra manera cuando estamos aplicando
la transformación a un vector escalado
esto sea lo mismo que escalar la
transformación del vector y del mismo
modo la segunda propiedad de la
linealidad es que si tú tienes la suma
de dos vectores del vector ven más el
vector w entonces al aplicarle esta
transformación lineal lo que tendríamos
que obtener es la transformación
aplicada al vector b ya esto sumarle la
transformación aplicada al vector doble
y esta es la segunda propiedad o dicho
de otra manera esto es lo mismo que
primero aplicar la transformación a cada
uno de los vectores por separado y
después sumarlos a sumar primero los dos
vectores y después aplicarles la
transformación ahora bien una de las
consecuencias más importantes de esta
definición formal de linealidad es que
si tú tomas una función la función l
y se aplica a un vector cualquiera voy a
pensar en el vector x bien entonces
cuando tú aplicar la función a este
vector lo que vas a obtener es lo
siguiente es lo mismo que aplicar la
función am x ojo estamos hablando de una
función lineal entonces va a ser x que
multiplica al vector canónico 1010 y a
esto sumarle 10 veces que va a
multiplicar al otro vector canónico al
vector canal ni con 0 1
0 1
y bueno esto es debido a las propiedades
que tenemos acá arriba a las propiedades
de linealidad si puedo separar a zinc no
importa si primero escalón y después
sumo o si lo hago al revés entonces esto
me va a quedar exactamente igual déjenme
bajar un poco la pantalla para que
sigamos trabajando esto me va a quedar
exactamente igual que x por cualquiera
que sea la transformación lineal de este
vector base es el vector canónico
entonces déjame ponerlo así x por la
función lineal aquí esta función se está
aplicando a este vector para que no
perdamos la notación la función lineal
aplicada al vector 10
ok
y a esto sumarle
diez veces que multiplica la función
lineal a lo que quiera que nos den la
función aplicada al otro vector pase al
vector 01 y bueno tal vez te sea mucho
más claro si lo aplicó para un ejemplo
tal vez sea más fácil si le pongo un
valor a este vector x m así que voy a
decir que este vector x que va a ser y
vamos a ponerle un cierto valor voy a
decir que esto va a ser igual al vector
21 vamos a ver qué pasa cuando le
aplicamos la transformación a este
vector entonces si buscamos sobre la
cuadrícula donde está el punto 2 1 este
punto en particular y después le
aplicamos la transformación quiero que
siga en este punto para ver dónde cae
iba a terminar justo aquí bien entonces
en términos de la cuadrícula anterior es
decir la cuadrícula original con la que
comenzamos el punto está ahora en
3 ahí es donde terminamos pero lo
importante y lo que quiero que noten es
que sigue siendo dos veces el vector
verde más una vez el vector rojo así que
satisfacen esta propiedad de x por
cualquiera que sea la versión
transformada de este vector base 10 más
que por la versión transformada del
segundo vector va a ser 0 1
entonces si hacemos un pequeño resumen
lo más importante es que cuando tengamos
un tipo de matriz como ésta que tengo
aquí pueden considerarla como una
transformación del espacio que mantiene
a las rectas de la cuadrícula paralelas
y uniformemente separadas y ese es un
tipo muy especial de transformación es
una propiedad muy restrictiva para tener
una función que manda puntos
bidimensionales a otros puntos
bidimensionales y la manera conveniente
de codificar esa idea es que el lugar
donde cae ese primer vector va a ser el
que comienza con una unidad a la derecha
está representado por la primera
de esta matriz y el lugar donde cae el
segundo vector base en el que está
apuntando con una unidad hacia arriba
está codificado por la segunda columna
de la matriz y si esto les parece
totalmente desconocido o quieren
aprender más acerca de esto pueden ver
los vídeos que he hecho anteriormente
pero en términos de la matriz hakobyan
am y tener un sentido geométrico para
esa matriz que es a donde vamos con este
pequeño resumen que di sobre álgebra
lineal debería de ser suficiente para
ponernos en marcha y con esto los
veremos en el siguiente vídeo